ATISSA BANUAZIZI:
So I think it's
somewhat of a misconception
that communication
can be separated from the
work that scientists do.
Because so much
of what scientists
do in their daily
lives is communication.
If you are a scientist, and
you are doing really, really
exciting work, that
work is not going
to have any kind of impact if
you can't tell people about it.
And a lot of the actual
work that scientists
do is writing up their results,
is talking about their results
in all kinds of settings
and to all kinds of people.
And MIT students, they're
very proud of their work.
And they want their
work to have impact.
And I think there
is an understanding
that the way to have
impact is to make sure
that other people understand it.
And if other people don't,
then the work languishes.
And there are all sorts
of reasons why people
want to communicate their work.
They may want to communicate
their work in classes, sure,
to get a good grade.
But they also eventually
will be asking for funding.
They will be
communicating their work
to change the direction of
research in their field.
They want to change the world.
That's going to happen if and
only if they can talk about it
and write about it effectively.